i was thinking that we can
do both
the intermediate and the advanced class
go over
enough decent game we've been i've been
at least doing it
quite routinely when there is a
top tournament in the world and we have
right now
the first major tournament of the year
one of the strongest
one in
netherlands they can say like uh
well old people like me remember it like
vacancy so we'll keep it
that way and
the first two games that we will see are
well
somewhat embarrassing losses maybe by
nakamura with the black pieces against
hari krishna that we're having a very
nice tournament and
by wesley saw which lost to dominguez
and
i just spoke upstairs with the grand
master feingold and
he was telling me that when he was
showing games from that tournament he
pretty much
showed both of those games at the same
time like he just showed them as one
game and i said it he actually told me
two games i told him immediately yeah i
know
it was the nakamura game in the saw game
because they are
almost identical in the idea of
something we spoke
last week here
keeping your king without enough
defenders the square around the king
something that we have mentioned well
quite several times and both of those
players actually unbelievable best
blitz players in the world top of the
top really got checkmated like really
checkmated like not or close to that
all right so let's start with
nakamura game
so playing against harvey creation that
i believe won
the tournament in 2012
the b section of course the b section
and the price for
winning the b section is to get to play
in the a section so he played the last
year and actually had a very decent
performance
he seems like one of the
nicest people out there so
they invited him again and so far he's
having
really great tournament all right so
he's playing against nakamura winner of
the tournament in 2011 okay player
number three in the world
already this move i think is tiny
indication by the way for black's
desiring play because bishop d7 is the
more common line
but the positions many times get to be
either equally so without
too many winning chances for black for
example
such move order
actually we have seen similar game
between carlson and anand which carlson
ended up winning within the last year
okay but knight d7 is clearly not
having fast exchanges it's why it's one
of those lines that
stating you want to fight
and
very interesting move bishop d3
i mean if someone's seen the game then
he knows but
what is the idea of bishop d3 because it
seems so
bizarre in the sense of blocking the
deep on how does white want to continue
here
exactly exactly and build the center
which we see
which we see in many
many systems are just a quick system i
will mention
is playing immediately c3
knight f6 and here white has basically
three main move h3 bishop e2 the pawn of
course cannot be taken because of check
right i've seen some games that
it was and bishop d3 and
this is one other idea so basically we
are getting similar territory just in a
different move order
okay
very good
black is immediately
attacking this and now rookie one
because
we want to play d4 so no d3
e5 okay
other than e5
i think there is one extremely critical
move
for black in this position
extremely critical move to consider at
least
which one is it
c4 yc4 yeah
i mean white want to play d4 and take
with
the c pawn basically white wants to get
these two pawns in the center so
by playing c4 you are interrupting right
you are
exactly
exactly
that's that's exactly exactly your
your plan
so for example something like this okay
black would be more or less comfortable
i would assume or maybe knight c5 and
going after the bishop is a possibility
so
which move would be normal for white
here
okay we are thinking in a very logical
way
so what's logical for white
huh
exactly
you want to attack this pawn of course
take take quite comfortable for why
white is achieving what he wanted more
or less i mean it's actually possible
this way
and if not
the c4 is a target i mean this is
another possibility definitely
i think a very interesting one to
consider i mean
i wonder let's see in a millisecond what
icc computer is thinking okay you've
seen
it was e5 was his first move okay e5 he
was zig-zagging between e5 that actually
was played by ikaro in the game let's
say he's saying white is three photons
better but okay not really that strong
computer just to get a feeling
and what does he say after c4
this mouse went insane
now i'm not joking
the mouse okay
okay so now he went to c4 all right
so
in
i i like c4 actually more
all right let's see exactly what we are
having c4 b4 and so on
okay
so icaro chose to play let's take a
computer away
yeah this would be the first move i
would be thinking just in the sense of
d4 i don't want to allow but okay e5
so now we are getting some sort of we
started with sicilian but which
structure we are getting now
huh
well the pi is right exactly like
zigzag here there but we are
exactly getting into an exactly exactly
very
direct territory the knight is going to
g3 and
yeah
rookie 8 knight g3
okay
what are the ideas that we know
for white to play in such positions
but okay but but okay 95 is the move not
an idea maybe maybe actually a decent
move but i think not by the way because
let's take one step back
look
it's maybe it's maybe not the most
logical thing but black played white lit
one two three moves immediately right
now
because if white is not playing it
immediately
black will be able to play castle who
create bishop f8
and then he will be threatening to take
and this pawn is under attack
so that's why the knight cannot move for
example
let let's say that white plays like okay
here
now white okay white can always play d5
that's another story but now white
cannot play knight f1
because take take and the pawn is
undefended so in the way lupez in the
main line it's always important that
your knight get to g3
before e4 is under attack too many times
and that's why i think
that knight f5 would not work
because and that's why i played d5
because if knight f5
take and the e4 pawn is quite lost
okay d5
okay
many times when
there is such a bishop on b7 many many
times the move d5 is almost
almost automatic
or at least an automatic way of thinking
g6
okay
how how should white be
playing here i mean what what what are
whites all the ideas alternatives here
the idea is that in so many openings so
many when you see those advanced pawns
yes they're taking away squares they're
controlling territory but they're also
targets
they're also targets or at least you
want to make them a target how many
games where b5 is being played and
almost automatically we see this a4
b3
rook b1
okay so it was
this version or another but we are going
to see some ideas such as
such as
a4
i think that he might not
maybe the reason he didn't play
immediately f4
was because of c4 and the knight maybe
heading to c5
that's that's my feeling
so he played first b3
and of course after c4 you would have
taken and the c pawn would be weak
for example something like that
bishop to a4
or knight to d2 just seems like white
god
look at the difference between the
bishops
this bishop on b7 is
the big problem for black
okay
so like we said a4 is a very principle
almost automatic idea
queen c7 okay
so here
big
question
what's the question here why white gave
white won a pawn
but
this pawn might be weak
well what is the question i think that
white should be
asking himself maybe it's a simple
answer but
yes
no no he moved his knight to a3 okay why
he's attacking the rook attacking the
pawn attack maybe i take the bishop
i mean white has a choice here to give
the light color bishop or to give yes
that's what you want to say julian yeah
i mean white can take and give his dark
color bishop or white can move the rook
and give the
light color bishop
every exchange is a huge question
should you exchange what you should
exchange every exchange
so
we're gonna have a
you know
vote
so dwight
give away
his light color bishop or
dark color okay who wants to give the
dark color bishop and play bishop take
knight
who is in favor of this move
wow
who is in favor of moving the rook
okay
who is thinking about
the weather outside
okay so there are multiple hands
all right
yeah
okay
i think it is correct to give away the
light color bishop
and i also think the reason is quite
obvious just by the pawn structure you
know you just see
all the squares that this bishop has
as opposed to
the light color bishop that is just
blocked so
after this you know suddenly bishop
takes a3 that's it i'm just quitting
all right log b3
so
black has some compensation that's true
the c file maybe some play with the
bishop here but all in all black
black
is worse i mean he got he got
he got a worse tiny worse position in
the opening and was outplayed
knight d7 okay
for example the light carter bishop can
never fight the square as opposed to a
dark color bishop so now knight c5 will
be met very powerfully with
yeah just take and okay that's already
where is the c file
this knight
gonna be here
absolutely dream square or maybe we can
also transfer this knight
no that's this is just
big pawn down
bishop a6 okay logical
rook
a3
also logical
i just want to clear the
oh you want to fight on the a file
because that's where you
can penetrate
bishop b5 okay
so it's clear that once again black
opening didn't really work and it's just
in trouble here but the main
thing i want to show actually is coming
very soon
rogue b8
ok 7
queen c8
maybe
something like this but
maybe take take
and then just get all start bringing the
pieces to that side i mean okay
just upon down i mean we can not
paint it in any
any any different way
h3 now this this is a pretty move it has
two huge purposes
which are
one so just you don't have to worry
about some future checkmates on the back
rank
yes julian
and definitely you can put your knight
on g4 excellent so h3 is just quite
automatic playing
knight b6
queen c1
okay why did he play queen c1
okay and what does he want to go next
h6
because there are some weaknesses around
the black king right i mean it's it's
clear that there are some weaknesses and
especially if the knight
might end up on g4
those squares are weak so good move
i mean i think black should be thinking
about you know
exchanging
maybe rooks suffering in whatever end
game that he has i mean maybe already
here unpleasant
you know
while
doing the you know while doing the video
right now i i remember carlson that he
once said about he
his defensive skills
and he said that you know some people
say like how can you defend this way and
so on and he said one of his great
qualities about himself and and still he
said it in a modest way which is correct
that
he has a
when you need to choose between
lash
everyone out to you know desperate
attack or all men in to guard i believe
those were very close to his world that
he can balance those very very well
which means i mean i think icao lost
this game immediately
because well okay he blundered but
he just didn't really want to go to
passive long
frustrating defense
but maybe for example carson would have
done it and after five six hours made a
draw
oh win most of those defenses
i mean doing this with black is not easy
but
i think that's what was wrong knight c4
so
julian i know that you remember
what did we say
about black's position black's king here
black is in tower right yes
isabel one thing
one other reason why should black be
worried here
yes
knight to g4 or g4 not to g5 i mean
you want to attack those squares so for
example this maneuver which was
suggested before is very powerful but
without even specific moves forget about
specific moves d squared that square
black only has a bishop
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you know
this is player number three in the world
that got checkmated and you know and if
he if he listen i don't know if ben
uploaded it on youtube but if you listen
to our lectures last week
do this dude like just go to youtube you
know saint louis channel
like remember we mentioned
last week we mentioned games like uh one
of the games was
we mentioned
um
benjamin buck against you young guy how
many attacking were on over there
actually the best game was the game of
dota against messick when black rook
returned
from e3 and there were no defenders zero
defenders around white king and just
white was lost and some other games that
bringing defenders would have saved no
defenders around the king none that's it
one and he's also disappearing soon
so if white will be able to somehow
get there
it's over that's it
and after this move
yeah he wants to attack the rook and so
on
and what now
julian suggested take
threatening check mate that's no joke
threatening checkmate but the seventh
ranked defense is like so crucial in so
many sicilians you have a piece here and
white is opening everything but
that's that's a huge huge huge
defensive idea
all right
so no
i mean maybe some versions but
but okay but the idea is correct i mean
the idea is
yes
so
what else
yes
no but first of all we want to attack i
mean if you want to go back that's
already
he can the knight will take the queen
will take
okay black
some black is maybe still worse but
somewhat
already feeling better because white
will have bad pawn structural means
still upon down but
no if we go all the way there
going back is somewhat is basically
admitting that we have nothing there
maybe it's true but
let's see if we do have something though
knight h5
okay bang
okay so now we have to we have a lot to
calculate
take the knight take the bishop
take the rook
what's happening okay let's start take
the knight on h5 what is right gonna
play
queen g5 king h8
king g8
and take on f7 right
this i see
so here here here here
and that's not really bad
all right
take the bishop
gonna take back
assume we're gonna take back
take
yeah but now actually how to checkmate
immediately
aha check right excellent
yeah and if here here
and that's it
and the same here
all right
so
and the thread is what knight f6
so take oh it didn't take i mean if take
how do we play
knight f6
here
yeah i think this was black's best line
actually
if i remember okay what computers said
and now
computer said
okay queen 86 is just checkmate no joke
and
the move h3 that was played several
moves ago
is so crucial imagine this position
without the move h3
then checkmate
no this way those moves are huge and
there are some amazing kasparov games
that not only h3 was crucial but also
the king was already on h2 because
to avoid some check on the back rank
some amazed some of the best attacking
games in history
so a computer i think suggesting this
move
but
yeah just not too good but okay this is
anyone can try this that is uh you know
free time
now play this position
so
bishop g7 take
maybe threatening checkmate
and that's definitely checkmate
no i clearly checkmate no joke no that's
that's incredible now let's see where
was black's crucial crucial mistake i
think queen c5 was just
a losing move
yeah it takes the computer tiny bit time
okay so what computer's saying right
saying okay
play rook a8
and you know
defend
okay plus one black had better
possibilities before to exchange
but okay rk8 okay
whatever not best computer in the galaxy
but still decent one saying
less than a point advantage for white i
wonder if before we could have
yeah quincy it like why not walk b7
okay the line that we suggested remember
we suggested take take in c4
once again okay
you know we are not miracle workers
right we cannot make magic white white
is better
but black has to find the best way to
survive best possible best chances to
survive and so queen c5 was just a huge
blunder by nakamura
yak
let's see how long here
finish
okay
well the interesting part is that okay
ikawa was just playing really really
well for many tournaments and getting to
be number three in the world after
carlos and naronian which is just really
playing
really playing well
kamnik was so so and speaking about so
so
someone that was
someone that would really been on fire
like for pretty much the last year and
maybe
not so many people follow because okay
it's not really you know like our top 10
karwana karyakin
nakamura but
wesley saw
like
really had an unbelievable
unbelievable year
having a great
great tournament great tournament here
until he lost to arghanian and
had this
not very pleasant game against
dominguez which
in some way i think has quite a lot of
similarities too well some similarities
to
the games we've just seen
okay
petrov
and i take yeah of course one of the
one of the
main lines i mean
is this knight c3 d4 is the other
the other line
and actually
you know i've seen some players play
even this ridiculous move and it seems
like really wrong and by any standards
white
looks like white is just going to be
much better
not so easy
i mean at least at least i mean white of
course better but
huh
yeah therefore the first bishop is seven
and sometimes after i
of course it has to be somewhat better
for white but
not really that easy i think i think
some players maybe maybe a game karyaki
and bujong jim maybe if or other chinese
players made a draw and some other
decent grandmasters have been
between
no okay i mean it's just like a temp i
mean
no nothing wrong no it's one other move
i mean i mean i think i think sometimes
it allows white
maybe some ideas quickly with
95 but maybe i think it's another main
move
i'm you know just for you i will check
for a second what is more what is more
um
no because i'm not certain somehow i i
remember bishop e7 is more
playable but
it will take us a second
take
so knight f6 we are interested in
yeah let's see
i've been played by okay for example
vashira against gili morozevich wang hao
against bhujangji some really many games
of yusuf okay he's super win 2008
so here we have
even two kari krishna actually halle
krishna played this against evan chukin
a tournament even took one with
white
and
the main movie is indeed bishop e7
bishop p7 bishop d3
anand kramnik
those are not really bad players that
was they they played this in blitz
against grishouk in a rapid
yeah kayaking wang hao
okay
that was last year and so on and
actually karjakin bhujangji i remembered
okay in 2012 was a draw
so
no it's a it's a tough line i mean you
know we have
extremely strong grandmasters
that are playing it and just to be
absolutely certain that
yeah and pretty much
pretty much knight f6 bishop e7 is
by far
more played than
d5 because you don't want to surrender
this square so quickly
all right
but it took took
now i have to say something
i
supposedly there is a book that i wrote
long ago that's going to be published
sometime actually probably sometime now
it's actually if surprisingly i can say
it's not me it's the publisher
but um
and i don't remember anything about the
patchwork but i wrote my book about the
patch of
i don't remember anything like i
remember the first two three moves
but
what
don't buy the book
i i strongly strongly recommend not to
no actually it's maybe not a bad one
but
i think that i have one one important
comment in the book
which says this
which says dude
if you're playing the patch off
then
you know play what the opening is uh you
know
what what the opening spirit is
and that is to get an incredibly solid
position
maybe slightly worse and make a door
okay you know kramnik is doing that
no i mean i mean and i i remember i
wrote a line there i just spoke to i
wrote a line saying
well don't get confused you're not
playing the night off if you want to
play the night off then
play the night off
i know i say that because one of the
best lines for example
that i believe so is to play this way
like
okay it doesn't matter at the exact
play knight c6
bishop e6
and then queen d7 and long castle if
white wants to get the bishop you know
let him have it you know but once again
which bishop to give i think that this
is the way they go
let him have the bishop okay you know
that's that's what you play
so is white tiny better here
maybe
is it easy to win for white
not really like
really really not really so you know
if you want to play something tiny
passive tiny
i mean okay there may be some different
lines would be whether with bishop g4 or
bishop e6
the reason i i wrote it it was in a
chapter that karjakin beat
karjakin big bitter kramnik
in one of the town memorials with
unbelievable game you remember the game
julian
no no 2010 i think no like unbelievable
like sacrificed the peace like no just
checkmated him the age father everywhere
and then he was winning also against
nakamura i think it was a draw but
no nakamura was also winning against
kamnik and what's the door no there were
some
some some problems started in this line
because you have to understand that
in 2008 for example
anand started playing d4
against kramnik in the match because i
thought he's going to have huge problems
what to play against the petrov i
remember i was on icc saying a few
months before the match
you know what is the not going to play
against the pet over like yeah d4 first
move no pet off
so
bishop p7
but actually this line
this line was played in some
some recent ideas and games were played
in this line and like black was doing
actually reasonably well i mean
we can
take a look at some
recent examples but there were some
games
i think i think one of them was anand
with the white pieces
let's see
b6 for example nakamura
played this against
wang hao
in the norway tournament i mean those
are best players
best players in the world like seriously
and there were there were
other other games with
those ideas
okay
so it's not anything like really
extremely new
long castle that's where following
the game
bishop b7
and h4 this is why
kinda i want the king to be on the other
side and
oh you know
i much prefer to be tiny worse than tiny
checkmated
okay 97
bishop d3
so like he's not joking like you know
he's like not like he's pointing
everything there and like
they would take back
but
yeah and here interesting
what to play here
i mean that that is an interesting
question
first of all i think that black
is lacking counter play here
while white has immediate played over
there i mean i just want to jump on him
like crazy like knight g5 bring the rook
here i don't know everything is really
aimed at the king
well what what what
c5
i think c5 was played i'm not certain i
like this move but okay on the other
hand
i'm not certain what should be liked in
this position
i mean
h6 is line suggested by computer but i
doubt it and
rookie rookie 8 is maybe ok eight or
maybe move the knight
but
to me okay we
maybe rookie 8
and then get the bishop here so you can
fight for the e4 square because it's
really important to stop
this bishop no because there's some
sacrifices there can be very nasty
okay now what's the problem with c5
d6 end
d5 right i mean it just weakened this
entire
entire squares there you know it's like
it's like you see some young kids
playing
super fast c5 when they have a pawn here
and just that's it they
gave away d5 d6
forever and ever and ever
okay take
queen f4
so what are the
ideas here i mean first of all even
position i think
why would i say what i think you tell me
what do you think is the idea of queen
of four
i mean what does he want to do here
let's say you will play queen g4 and you
can then play this so no sacrifice
but what are which other ideas are out
there
yeah exactly this is one thing just
positionally let's say black plays king
h8 you just want to play here
i if this move i think
c4 and we're gonna win the pawn right
something like that
and and if take
okay then
so weak
just
clearly white is better and very nice to
see how those pawns
are fighting against
this bishop i mean if white pawns were
on c4 b3 okay
maybe tiny bit some counter play but
spawns on b2 c3
no nothing there
yeah i i think that bishop before his
minimum
position idea
i was also thinking maybe g4 in some
situation is something to consider
the problem with g4 right now i think is
bishop e5
but
if not
knight g5 is another possible idea you
just want to bring the pieces over
though
d5
h5
yeah i wonder why
if knight g5 immediately could have been
played maybe this was the move
and then okay black is surviving
no h5
because bishop g5 and so on
but very dangerous all of those things
are super dangerous but now queen five
is really straight i think
in g4
so
what's the problem here i mean we can
look at that much deeper but
that's not our purpose
i think that the way i see it is there's
one player that is playing here and
that's white and the question is whether
black can maybe be okay or not
it means that something went tiny bit
wrong with his play
okay maybe c5 c5 was definitely one move
to blame
and also this idea about short castle is
probably okay
but
maybe matter of taste but
yeah now
if is this move absolutely necessary
i don't know somehow
such a move is really scary
g4
i mean i can tell you g6 i can tell you
the computer wants to get counter play
open some lines
that's at least computer idea
and g6
very very dangerous
i mean we we said here several times
right the danger about pushing pawns
when your opponent is attacking
okay so take take by the way
once again okay there are some defenders
here but
it looks very very
dangerous the white rook is there the
queen the knight the bishop
yeah exactly so basically white is
pretty much with everything and the
other who can come over
exactly so this piece is not defending
at all this piece not and the queen's
semi
right but at least it's covering the f6
square but yeah you would much prefer to
have the queen on g7 for example
all right
g5
has to go here and here well really
interesting what was played
quite a standard ideas but
yeah
okay seven we many times see it for
example when there is a king on g7 like
we see the in in kids puzzles okay you
will have this position and then
y to plane win
right so that's a much easier version
rook 287 check
distracting the king taking it away from
defending f7 check
and checkmate winning doesn't matter how
but okay but this is tiny bit
same idea
but much more complicated so white
basically just want to go and
see if he can checkmate on
on the h file i mean take take
is really going to be
checkmate
default
okay it's logical because he wants to
take the knight and then take on
g5 with air check
right
bishop c4
yeah and queen e7 was a move that
just
not that great move
but it but it was really really
difficult to see
how black can survive first of all
how to defend the pawn on f7 what's
possible to defend it
look at eight
book g7
okay okay rookie no but but rocky seven
is resigning on the spot now
let's first of all start having a few
guidelines
if rookie 7 take take check
and checkmate
so if white gets the f6 square it's over
so for example you can also reject
bishop d5
on the same token exactly take take take
here
and checkmate
right so so so if we get this square and
then we combine the rook it's over
okay one
so look f8
okay
focus 8 i thought that this is
mamma mia dangerous
yeah i think this is losing okay white
wanna take and go queen h6 and rook h1
and if take
you know this this pin that
pretty much everyone misses but let's
say that we are not going to miss
and then this and kind of checkmate
so that's quite serious
yeah the only move but
you know wesley so
not easy to find people that calculate
faster than him on this planet no really
not easy but he
just
like it's just like
too much to think about allowing this
maybe what
maybe what he missed is that
in such continuation
he has this move and it's not checkmate
this block
maybe maybe overlook this
i'm not certain but wow
in in some things i mean
this this i mean there's some crazy
too crazy lines i think this is what
computers say take take
here
and he says white is better here but i
i'm not certain it's totally
winning
too complicated for us
but look how the game finished i mean he
he had to take on f3 i believe at least
yeah computers say maybe maybe it's
still really bad position maybe even
lost but
after this move
maybe he thought maybe he thought about
luke h1 only and then
thought that he can take
and eliminate the pawn and maybe
maybe survive
but after this move you just resign
yes
you